all right so let me ask you this
question you meant you mentioned that
you submitted for some promotions yeah
but you didn't get them no I didn't get
them what would you say to somebody who
said that you're leaking of this
information was just because you were
angry they didn't promote you that's a
valid point I mean you you wanna if you
have any whistleblower comes forward you
want to examine their motives right and
so
um yeah I mean that's a valid point
something that I I also mentioned in the
video that came out is um okay well
first you got to realize okay here my if
I got a promotion how much more money
would I be making I don't know how like
a dollar 25. okay so I was making 15
bucks an hour I was making like 28 grand
a year yeah and so if I got a promotion
I'd be making 16 an hour uh Facebook
promised us that we'd get like uh an
increase but our project ended before
that so they're going to increase like
18 an hour base but I was everyone was
making the same I was making I even knew
Spanish I was in the Spanish I was I was
making 15 an hour but um
but yes I wouldn't it would have helped
with my resume I guess uh maybe my
advancement yeah a better title so just
to clarify you're saying it was not a
factor no it wasn't a factor so I only
asked that because the next question is
at what point were you like I've gotta
do something and I've got to just
release all this stuff
so may have it's funny because uh there
was actually another someone else
another Insider who blew the whistle on
like wrongdoings at cognizant who felt
that they weren't helping us enough with
our mental health and so I remember that
story yeah The Verge story so February
2019 this journalist Casey Newton he
actually came to to the site in Phoenix
and he I saw him there and he he walked
around and he wrote an article about it
and so in a way that might have been a
little bit of inspiration for me because
I had some information that was kind of
bothering me that I'd seen some examples
of bias so that that may three months
later in May of 2019 I wrote a letter to
Congress or to a few congressmen
with about 19 examples of bias and I
didn't hear back and that's when I
started reaching out to a couple
journalists can you name them
um so I mean I'll just say that I ended
up with project Veritas someone referred
me I'm not sorry I'm not surprised you
mentioned uh uh I was gonna say when you
mentioned Casey Newton I was like oh did
he go in and cheer for the censorship
he's at the Verge I know I know the
funny thing is like since you think he'd
be interested in another hey I had an
Insider at this location another guy
from the same exact location came
forward with video evidence you'd think
he'd be interested in it but I searched
his what their website there's zero
mention of me or project Veritas I don't
think they're fans of project Veritas so
you know you don't want to mention which
other organizations reached out to uh
you don't have to I don't want to
pressure you to do it no uh not not at
this time but um it did bother me
because I that I think I saw something
where did I see that may
May of 2019
there were a lot of things that bothered
me but you know one of the things that
bothered me the most I think that came
out that I saw in 2018 was they made an
exception to allow calling straight
white males Phil filth so they said hey
every summer there's this pride month
um and we're going to make an exception
to allow attacks on straightway Mills
for not supporting LGBT so stream my if
you say straight away Mills are filth
for not supporting LGBT that's allowed
so they're probably got an exception
um and then what they changed the policy
to
allow the phrase white trash which is
almost synonymous with Trail trash so I
kind of understand but at the same time
do you remember when those racist do you
remember those feminists also getting
banned for saying hashtag kill all men
were you there at the time when that
happened no no recall that I know we
made an exception of South Africa when
there was domestic violence against
women where they allowed the phrase men
are trash wow that's just a bad idea
it's so stupid it sounds like morons
from these companies forgive me if your
friends some of these people still
that's the stupidest thing I've ever
heard hey there's a bunch of tension and
animosity between people best and
identity can we inflame that yes let's
let's let's let's let's yeah okay yeah
so uh did you tell James O'Keefe that he
was uh that you're that he's your bronze
medal wait did I say it right he was
your not your first choice or whatever
I'm kidding I'm kidding uh yeah so there
was a time so when I for first year out
around June of 2019 I first contacted
project Veritas and then we talked a
little bit and I think I filmed the
first time around June of 2019
um and then I didn't respond for a
little while I like it was I don't know
I didn't check my email or whatever and
then later that fall we started talking
again
so I didn't film it and then we found
that the project was ending cognizant
shows that and the the project the
cognizant and so I started filming more
regularly
um but yeah so that the February 2019
the The Verge article came out and I
didn't agree with some of it because I
feel like they had like cognizant did a
really good job of helping us with our
mental health we had counselors on site
24 7. we had a psycho like a
psychiatrist who was in charge of
everything
and so we had a number to call they gave
us Wellness time like 10 like 10 minutes
a day so were you right leaning before
taking this job I was I heard I heard
another story that people are getting
red pilled by moderating this content
because they see so many right wing
memes that they start to be like hey
wait a minute you know is that something
you've ever you experienced like not you
personally like did you see anybody who
was like hey I saw this thing
I don't know if I didn't I don't know
anyone personally I know I know the some
people were like more open to conspiracy
theories or like you know the art
flatter theories things like that so it
didn't expose you to different
viewpoints and you did get a darker
sense of humor you got kind of like a
Gallows humor from working there would
you did you have like really nasty
inside jokes like the 12th time you saw
an incest video and like everyone's like
oh one of those huh like you guys are
laughing about the horror of it all you
know similar types of of humor
um I I say this because people use humor
to release the tension right yeah so I'm
wondering if like you're watching like
videos of murder and like all this crazy
stuff and then someone's just cracking
really dark jokes about it to try and
bring some like levity to the situation
you know yeah I think that can be
effective in a way I mean therapy I mean
a way of dealing with it
um one strategy that was kind of cool
that they thought that one of the
counselors taught me is if you're seeing
something really violent you don't
really want to empathize you want to you
want to visualize yourself in a movie
theater
and then there's another another you
standing in the back of the theater so
you're watching yourself in the movie
movie seat watching the film and the
film is what you're seeing in the video
so it kind of distances and detaches
yourself from
from the actual content it's weird but
um yeah I had co-workers who man they
they had they saw child porn that it
really bothered them wow dude that's
really bad but it was it was a small
percentage so some of it was like really
fighting down yeah like I couldn't I
couldn't imagine someone doing that job
you see that stuff and then like you
just want to track these people down
like you you see their profiles right
like you you can see their personal
information so not not too much personal
information sometimes it's their profile
photo and their name but it should be
fake I'm sure it's crossed through
people's minds I hunt these people down
oh yeah like wow dude and then uh could
that be a cool superhero film I guess to
be too gritty like a dude as a Content
moderator for Facebook dude that would
be a good thing every time he sees a
video he just likes like like kind of
like like Liam Neeson yeah I will find
you I will find you like the guy gets a
Facebook message and he's like I'm a
Facebook content moderator I will find
you I will destroy you it would be like
Dexter you know like this dude just like
has their Facebook information
I I couldn't imagine working a job like
that man I don't know how you did it for
almost two years yeah we it was tough
there were times but you know luckily I
wasn't able to I didn't bring it home
very often
um and I think there's you know there's
a lot of people who struggle with it
more than others
um but it was just it was a unique job
in a way though if you could get past
that it was a cushy type of job I mean
it was if you could get past it I mean
yeah if you could get past it but we
have just the weirdest conversations
like you know hey is this because we've
got definitions for like you know if I
can say this like for erections like is
this is it is the shape you know you've
got really Nuance in the detail so you
have you'd have conversations with your
co-workers like oh man what do you think
of this
I'm imagining like a dude walking up to
like the there's like a guy's like you
know putting cream in his coffee and
it's like you know so I got a video
today and it was like this guy's got a
screwdriver right he's holding this
other guy down while strangling him and
he lifts his arm up and then it cuts out
I'm wondering is that too much
yes so I'm gonna link I'll check it out
I'll let you know what I think and then
it's like I can't figure hey Janet come
over here and take a look at this guys
he's choking some guy he's about to like
literal that's not that's crazy yeah was
that was that what it was like it was
that's exactly
oh man I I can't help feeling that there
are some parallels here between what you
did and what we used to go through in
the hospital because we would talk about
these horrible horrifying things and you
have to make a joke about them you just
have to yeah well you can't yeah you
just can't go with it yeah you have to
deal with it somehow right and but you
should know maybe that's why why this
this is why I wasn't affected as much
like I actually had a stint at the
funeral home yeah so you know we used to
have a lot of people under us
if you work at a at a funeral home
you're probably started laughing yeah I
can't I kind of got up but I was like
wait is that it is it is that wait wait
what am I missing did you guys ever
watch bangedup.com back in the day a
couple decades I was just gruesome
people getting killed videos the Faces
of Death yeah stuff like that that's
like the video series 2001 two three
years I used to watch that that kind of
prepped me for this dude I remember my
friends would share like the Faces of
Death VHS
it was literally just videos of people
dying and I was just like why would you
put that on I was like we got we got
I've got Fast Times at Ridgemont High on
VHS let's put that in that one's got
boobs in it
I would try and watch military head cams
like a soldier getting shot and like
bleeding out as he's like screaming
because my theory was if it happened I
should expose myself to it and it kind
of works but it can also drive you
insane I I actually I actually agree I
remember there would there would be
these like these viral videos
periodically that were extremely
gruesome and people would be like don't
watch it don't watch and I'll be like I
kind of feel like you shouldn't hide
from what's what's out there and I'm not
saying to go around and watch every
single video and you know like you watch
one you say I get it but don't but yeah
don't hide from it because I've seen
stuff in real life you know I've seen
people get shot and killed I've seen
some pretty brutal stuff and that's why
you know it was funny when you were
bringing up the counseling and all that
stuff I'm like if I watched a video of
someone you know getting seriously hurt
or like some violence or Gore yeah I
could easily handle it but then you went
into like the child stuff and I was like
oh that's one out probably just like my
head would explode smashing things yeah
exactly yeah so it's like you're taking
off work and you're like loading a you
know 12 gauge or whatever and they're
like where are you going today I just
got some work I got some stuff to do
after this guy's profile I'll be back
tomorrow maybe not I might be in prison
yeah yeah when I was watching when I was
watching what was happening with project
Planet Pizza I don't know if you
remember the pizzagate story there was
somebody who went there with a gun and I
was like I was honestly just surprised
it wasn't a girl because if you really
believe that kids are being abused
you're gonna you're gonna make stuff
that's what's scary though because that
was so dumb yeah like that's not right
this building doesn't even have a
basement but you see so I'll tell you
what in that regard I do kind of
understand why they want to moderate
some content yeah I mean you were
mentioning like graphic scenes you know
we would see like car accidents people
dying suicide videos time also uh I was
gonna say tambien which means also in
Spanish sometimes I switch the two
um but I mean like but graphical I was
gonna say so remember that that
trumpsman Viral meme like from the
kingsman movie there was this Trump's
been meaning and we actually yeah we
categorized that so it showed so it
showed a scene from this fictional movie
Kingsman where there's a lot of violence
and it was like killing the media right
yeah killing the media and so I had the
real photos photoshopped in but like in
the graphic violence Paul so we actually
put an interstitial on that they told us
to Mark as disturbing mad yeah and so
like and I could see an argument for
just leaving it up because it's
fictional it's a fictional scene and
wasn't Trump like it's it's like so
kingsman's an awesome movie and it's
like this is really graphic scene where
he's killing it's in a church it was
actually I think Colin Firth was the
actor and it was in the movie oh this is
what's really really funny I mean kind
of disturbing in the movie Kingsman
definitely watch I love this movie Colin
Firth goes to this like really extremist
church and the villain triggers this
kind of sound thing that makes everyone
go nuts and become extremely aggressive
well Colin first character is a secret
agent of measurable skill and he kills
every single person and it's gruesome
yes now here's what's funny my
understanding that's okay putting up a
video on Facebook a scene from a movie
where a British guy in a suit a
gentleman brutally murders a bunch of
Southern church goers totally fine but
superimposed logos from media companies
on it and put Trump's face on the
British guy whoa whoa whoa and the same
thing happens in Brazil too like
president bolsonaro who when he was
running for president in Brazil he
actually got stabbed I remember that it
was like it was like a long knife wasn't
it yeah I don't know the exact length
yeah yeah huge knife it was it was a
life-threatening moon like it was it was
a big deal that was crazy and so he yeah
so you got stabbed instant then there
was memes showing uh like a a cartoon
meme showing bolsonaro with a a knife
coming out kind of like a boomerang and
coming back Landing back on him so it
was mocking or like you know mocking the
events of this of him almost dying and
Facebook allows that gee and so I mean
Brazil is is another animal as well I
mean Brazil there's a lot of tech
censorship I think it goes on there I
was there like last month I met with a
congresswoman in Brazil and their their
Supreme Court is just targeting
conservatives like I met a couple people
whose homes were raided by the Supreme
Court because they were supporting
right-wing news organizations wow and so
these people they want to use they want
actually want the U.S the US's help to
uh use the magnitude act magnets act
against
um the Brazilian Supreme Court so I mean
yeah it's it's happening there and
they're looking at this election coming
up and wondering what's going to happen
because a lot of countries in the world
are looking at the U.S hey if if Trump
doesn't win
things are going to get a lot worse for
us in Brazil yeah in Brazil and
everywhere else because
there were such a big strategic Ally and
they looked to us for for leadership as
far as you know our basic freedoms and
whatnot I think it's funny I think it's
funny that the people who oppose Trump
call themselves The Resistance and
they're literally on the side of every
major multinational corporation and big
Tech conglomerate authoritarian
structure but Donald Trump this one guy
tell you what they resist him he's if
he's a dictator he's pretty bad at it
because you think by the by this time
after four years he would have taken
control of you know Facebook and Twitter
but if you well it's funny that you know
I spend my life growing up hearing from
the left that the corporations are the
problem and the government will save us
and then I hear from the right no the
government is bad and corporations are
fine and I'm being very general with
this yeah now you get the left that
they're basically like corporations and
government are great which sounds very
much like fascism huh you know they've
got they've got roving bands of of like
this this is crazy in San Francisco
there was a dude there were people
putting on a a protest of big Tech
censorship one of the dudes was a black
dude and antifa punched him in the face
knocking his teeth out and my question
is just like wait so you got a black
dude who's protesting against
multinational billionaires who are
stifling his speech so you punch him in
the face sounds like you're the fascist
man like you're you're punching someone
I'd be on behalf of a major corporation
billionaires yeah like you're the you're
the brown shoot brown shirt man oh
it's yeah it's it's pretty insane
um yeah the whole corporate mentality I
mean so you now you have these huge
corporations like bending to uh the the
black lives matter movement and in none
of these groups are hate orgs so the
dangerous individuals and organizations
policy deals with these organizations
like any criminal organization so we
have a list of cartels that we would
delete on a regular basis terrorist
organizations obviously
uh but they added something there and it
said not allowed we delete people
notable for attacking people based on
protected characteristics So based on
the race ethnicity gender but it's such
a broad definition okay who are these
people that are notable where's the list
because we had the list of hate figures
so we like they had the list where we
had any other hate figures because it's
on the list that Facebook gives us okay
so Facebook created the list yeah
Facebook defined them as interesting
yeah do you find them as hate figures um
so so that was Paul Joseph Watson like
Milo Alex Jones right so on the list
that I had I I for sure saw Gavin
McInnis and Tommy uh so and so and so
yeah I don't know if we're about to say
his number but yeah uh Gavin McInnis
we're talking about them neutrally so
we're not we're not praising Christ
consider that you can't say someone's
name is insane well yeah so with these
1984 isn't it so bizarre like you
couldn't say people's names backwards we
should stop that no I mean like wasn't
that literally in the book where it was
like a person's name wasn't allowed to
be said or something guys the Brave New
World yeah anyway so yeah PSR praise
support or represent you cannot do any
support or represent of these
individuals and so Gavin McInnis and
Tommy Tommy are literally on the same
list as Adolf Hitler
I'm not [ __ ] you wow and so
um yeah so this is the hate figure list
so I mean This Is How They count and the
The Source they use that I have evidence
The Source they use is the ADL and the
uh Southern Property that's what I was
asking right because so uh the splc went
through its own major Scandal where
apparently they were being run by
racists and like that there was an
investigation that found Decades of
racism and that the organization itself
was essentially just a bunch of racists
making money off pretending to be not
racist yeah and then storing a bunch of
that money overseas or something yeah
the ADL has its issues but I gotta be
honest when you like when when you read
articles from Anti-Defamation League
like we had Enrique tario of The Proud
boys here uh it was it was I would say
extremely critical like uh ahead of
extremely negative View
but it was
decent assessment I should say like they
said they're clearly not white
supremacists though they have had
members who overlap and I'm like that's
true yeah even they've talked to us
about like oh yeah we had to kick these
people out for these reasons yeah and so
I think the ADL is the problem with the
ADL
is that their their their their their
view of everything is extremely negative
and they view all these groups like
they take a I don't I don't know how to
describe it other than
they're very very opinionated to an
extreme degree you know you do one wrong
thing and they're like ah that person's
evil but they'll mention what you did
and why they're mad about it they just
get mad really easily so they're
probably Law Center as far as I'm
concerned it makes it all up like they
had one article uh that included me
where they claimed that I went to a
Iranian Holocaust deniers conference and
their evidence for it was an archived
version of a of a website that didn't
exist anymore that was a holocaust
deniers website saying that I was an
attendee I've never been to sue them for
that so there was a suit
um they they settled immediately and
issued apology and they they said I was
a leftist how about that they were like
they basically said we apologize to
people who are on the left Tim pool you
know so and so so and so whatever thanks
for checking out this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast we do the show live
Monday through Friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification Bell and we
are also available on all podcast
platforms for free if you want to listen
to us there thanks for hanging out and
we will see you all next time